let's stick with the phone 6 1 7 8 3 0
47 50 I'm gonna try once more with the
caller from 7 1 8 caller from 7 1 8
what's your name where are you calling
from and what's on your mind today how
you doing David my name is Julio you
hear me I hear you Julio go ahead I do a
man from the Bronx New York
quick question a big fan of your show
Thank You Man love to you and Pat
question is um there was I read an
article in the New York Post about a
year ago that it's a migration are
people leaving and clean out of New York
yes
you know the style of living in New York
is getting too expensive you think you
have you read from your research
anything similar that applies to the
United States where people are guess
just fed up are probably going to Canada
or Europe are you saying for political
reasons or for cost-of-living reasons
both oh okay things I guess I mean
number one the whole if X gets elected
I'm moving to Canada thing you know how
people always say I'll move to Canada if
this person or that person gets elected
it barely ever happens people by and
large are rooted if not in the exact
city where they live certainly in the
state and and if not the state the
country where they live so very few
people actually are moving for political
reasons now is cost of living is
interesting
overall more people in the United States
are moving to cities we're seeing a move
towards urbanization and wanting to live
in more urban communities than rural
communities I don't know specifically
with New York City I mean the cost of
living in some of the most expensive
cities New York San Francisco Boston
Washington DC Los Angeles it's possible
that some of the individual cities are
experiencing people leaving now now the
thing with New York City that's
interesting is and I lived in Brooklyn
for a couple years some of the people
that are leaving the city proper are not
moving away from the region like they're
still working in New York but they might
move across the Hudson River you know to
Jersey City or Hoboken or something like
that or even further out so I don't
actually know the numbers I mean even
even when I was in New York the even
parts of the Bronx are getting really
expensive right which was historically a
less expensive area correct
correct my wife is French and sometimes
it's cheaper for us to buy a plane
ticket and send her back to France for
for health issues than it is to go to a
hospital here Wow even considering going
to France are living out there so how
much is one during that applied
nationwide with people are hearing about
the free health care in our some of
these European countries and they're
saying you know what let me give it a
try and move a few years to Euro we're
just wondering you've read at anything
on on that no I mean you know met
there's a couple different things you're
talking about one is moving away for
political reasons it's not hugely
happening medical tourism does happen
although generally speaking people
aren't going to France for medical
tourism they're going either to Latin
America or Asia but yeah anecdotally all
of this stuff happens so yeah I mean I
think it's they're all interesting
issues but I don't know to what extent
they're really affecting the population
of the US Thank You Man I appreciate
appreciate the answer all right Julio
great to hear from you we will take a
break and then continue taking your
phone calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50